la mesure était déjà actif sur les
marchés brocantes et vide-greniers elle
est désormais élargie porter un masque
est obligatoire dorénavant aux abords
des établissements scolaires et
universitaires ainsi qu'autour des gares
ferroviaires
l arrêté du préfet des yvelines prévost
pendant un mois dans un rayon de 50
mètres autour de ces sites pour les
personnes de plus de 11 ans en cette
matinée de rentrée dans cette école
primaire du vésinet la mesure est plutôt
bien accueillie et rassure les parents
c'est important pour protéger la santé
des autres et la santé de nos enfants
moi je pense que c'est une bonne chose
qu'il faut porter le masque dès lors
qu'on sort de son de son domicile il
faudrait que ce soit généralisé dans
toute la ville pour pâques et
d'ambiguïté pour savoir si oui on peut
le porter ici si oui on peut pas le
porter dans une dizaine de communes des
yvelines les mères avaient anticipé
l'arrêté préfectoral et pris des
décisions similaires dès le mois d'août
c'est le cas d'ailleurs au vésinet où le
port du masque est obligatoire dans
plusieurs lieux de forte affluence de la
ville depuis le 17 août
j'appelle cette décision par principe de
précaution puisqu'il y avait une
évolution quand même assez significative
du virus dans les yvelines et donc on a
voulu le faire suffisamment tôt avant
que les gens reviennent de vacances de
façon à les habituer et d'avoir une
bienveillance sur la première semaine de
l'arrêter pour que après tout soit bien
respecté même stratégie du côté de la
municipalité de villepreux qui avait
pris ses dispositions dès le 17 août
également après une phase de tolérance
auprès de la population la fermeté sera
de mise l'arrêté est respectée en tout
cas le port du masque est respecté il ya
eu un petit moment on va dire où il ne
l'était pas c'était le temps que
l'arrêté soit compris et soit connue de
tous notamment de la part des
commerçants mais globalement aujourd'hui
c'est bien respectée en continu sur le
terrain à faire de la pédagogie de la
communication et puis avec la police
municipale on rentrera aussi maintenant
dans une phase de faire de verbalisation
à si besoin est l'amendé pour non
respect de l'arrêté peut grimper jusqu'à
135 euros
depuis le 27 août les yvelines ont été
placées en zones de circulation active
de lakovic 19